la enésima derivada de gm en x igual a 0
está dada por la derivada enésima de gm
evaluada en 0 es igual a la raíz
cuadrada de n 7 entre n al cubo para n
mayor o igual a 1 cuál es el coeficiente
para el término que contiene a x
cuadrada en la serie de mclaren para gm
bien pues vamos a pensar un poco en las
series de mclaren para gm si fuera a
tener mi función gtx entonces lo que me
dice la serie de mclaren es que ésta gtx
se va a ver aproximadamente igual
y digo aproximadamente porque me voy a
tomar un montón de sumandos va a ser
aproximadamente igual a la función
primero evaluada en cero y esto dividido
a su vez en 30 factorial y después nos
tomamos la suma de éste con la primera
derivada evaluada en 0 esto a su vez
dividido entre 1 factorial que
multiplica a x
y bueno a esto les sumaríamos la segunda
derivada evaluada en 0 esto a su vez
dividido entre 2 factorial ok que
multiplica a x cuadrada y bueno nosotros
queremos este coeficiente el coeficiente
para el término que contiene a x
cuadrada en la serie de mclaren para gm
este coeficiente si nos pedían el
coeficiente para el término que
contienen a x cúbica bueno seguiríamos
estos serían más la tercera derivada la
tercera derivada evaluada en cero
recuerda que puedo poner así a la
tercera derivada o puedo escribir la
tercera derivada justo así la tercera
derivada déjame ponerlo de g evaluada en
cero ok ahora para seguir con el mismo
patrón voy a ponerlo como la tercera
derivada ok está evaluada en cero
dividido entre tres factorial entre tres
factorial que multiplican a x cúbica y
así podría seguir
y seguir pero bueno a nosotros lo que
nos interesa es esta parte de aquí lo
que queremos es el coeficiente para el
término que contienen a x cuadrada
entonces lo que buscamos es esto de aquí
la segunda derivada evaluada en cero y
está dividido entre 2 factoriales ahora
para saber esto necesitamos encontrar
cuál es la segunda derivada de g
evaluada en 0 y ellos nos dicen justo
por aquí de una forma un poco inusual
nos dan una fórmula para encontrar
cualquiera de las derivadas en x igual a
cero nos dicen que la enésima derivada
de g evaluada en cero es justo lo que es
el principio es igual a la raíz de n 7
entre n cúbica pero en este caso n no es
igual a 0 n es la derivada que estamos
buscando y en este caso va a ser nuestra
segunda derivada
así que si escribimos que en mi primer
evaluada en cero o la segunda derivada
evaluada en cero
esto se entiende mejor si lo escribo
como la segunda derivada evaluada en 0
observa que tenemos este mismo patrón va
a ser exactamente igual y ahora n vale 2
así que aquí en lugar de poner voy a
poner a 2 y entonces me quedaría la raíz
principal de 2 + 7
esto a su vez dividido entre 2 elevado
al cubo es justo lo que nos dice esta
expresión de aquí en lugar de nm pongo 2
tengo la segunda derivada evaluada en 0
y bueno esto va a ser igual a la raíz
principal de 2 + 7 279 la raíz principal
es 3
entonces me quedarían 3 y 2 al cubo es
83 octavos
y esto es lo que vale la segunda
derivada evaluada en 0 pero después hay
que dividir esto entre dos factores así
que el coeficiente que buscamos que es
la segunda derivada evaluada en cero
entre dos factorial esto va a ser igual
que tres octavos esto me queda en el
numerador y en el denominador me queda
dos factorial que es dos por uno lo cual
es dos así que esto va a ser igual ok si
pongo uno acá abajo me quedan tres sobre
16 y es justo lo que estábamos buscando
así que ya acabamos en esta ocasión no
quieren que encontremos todos los
términos para la serie de mack loring g
de 0 entre ser factorial más que prima
de 0 entre 1 factorial etcétera todo
esto de aquí lo podemos llamar el
polinomio de macro link o el polinomio
de macro ahora integrado el m pero en
esta ocasión no quieren que encontremos
todo el polinomio lo único que queremos
es saber cuál es el coeficiente esto es
lo que nos pedían el coeficiente para el
término que contienen a x cuadrada que
es justo lo que acabamos de encontrar
nuestra respuesta sería 3 sobre 16 y
hemos acabado